Urbana AR-15 Man Fan
do you think that you're more likely to
be killed by a knife or an AR-15 in the
United States
what if I told you that according to FBI
statistics four times as many people die
every year from knives or cutting
instruments they're delusional I don't
know it's the FBI I don't believe that
because there's mass shootings all the
time so I don't know there is mass
shootings all the time there's also
knife homicides you guys think that we
should ban knives I
I don't know I think guns are a bigger
issue so he's obviously right and the
lib ladies are wrong but in their
defense their conclusion was I don't
believe the FBI which after the past
five or six years fair enough they've
got a point